US President Donald Trump is arrived in
London at the beginning of a three-day
visit to the United Kingdom no Trump has
visited the country before this is his
first state visit to the UK and comes at
a time of political turmoil for Britain
Trump is already still at some
controversy when he voiced support for
the divisive political figure Boris
Johnson to be the next prime minister
and said that the UK should be much
tougher with the European Union during
brexit negotiations joining me now is DW
correspondent Charlotte Paz she's in
London in front of Buckingham Palace now
i'm shawna Donald Trump's this is his
first state visit so lots of pomp and
pageantry but what's on the agenda
during this three-day visit so Donald
Trump will receive first of all today
the full Royal Treatment he will arrive
here shortly at Buckingham Palace where
he's due to meet the Queen and Prince
Charles among others and the rest of the
royal family they will have a lunch
followed by a visit to Westminster Abbey
and a Royal Exhibition and then the
highlight of today for President Trump a
state dinner a banquet tonight where
Americans and British alike will attend
famous people from both countries
tomorrow then president Trump is going
to meet Theresa May in Downing Street
the outgoing Prime Minister where they
will discuss the possibility of a US UK
trade deal after brick said so that is
that those are the main things on his
agenda these days and of course
President Trump is hoping to create
glamorous images here in London during
his state visit
but Charlotte apart from the glamorous
images is hoping to get he's expected to
meet with quite a number of protests
isn't he
massive protests are indeed expected in
the capital today and tomorrow
protesters from all around the country
are indeed descending on London and
tonight they are planning to protest
here in front of Buckingham Palace
tomorrow then in central London around
Downing Street where Theresa May and
Donald Trump will meet we've also heard
a lot of criticism on this controversial
visit from UK politicians among them
amongst them opposition leader Jeremy
Corbyn the Labour leader who said he's
not going to attend the dinner tonight
he is going to boycott this dinner along
with other politicians here in the UK
Trump is visiting the UK at a time of
political turmoil over brexit and as we
heard Donald Trump has already aired his
views on the subject Hausa going down
there while Donald Trump has always been
a massive supporter of brexit of the UK
leaving the European Union he has
criticized Teresa May tremendously for
not negotiating in a right way with the
European Union and now he has finally
also endorsed Boris Johnson an avid
brexit supporter as the next prime
minister of course there is a lot of
criticism here surrounding that people
are saying a foreign leader should not
meddle with domestic politics but also
Boris Johnson supporters of course feel
like this was the right step from
President Donald Trump to do Charlotte
box outside the Buckingham Palace in
London thank you very much